Traducteur: Mohand Habchi
Relecteur: eric vautier
Beaucoup de conférences que j'ai regardées
pour préparer celle-ci
commençaient par une question,
et en général c'est ça qui m'intéresse.
Comme c'est ma 1ère conférence,
je vais m'inspirer de ce que j'ai vu
et je vais commencer
par vous poser une question :
que voyez-vous ?
C'est facile, comme question,
et en même temps, c'est un peu piège.
Vous voyez la personne qui est
en face de vous, qui ne vous voit pas.
Et qui vous demande ce que vous voyez.
Il y a plein de réponses possibles.
Justement, vous avez quelqu'un
en face de vous qui ne vous voit pas
et qui est obligé de vous parler.
Et vous, qui me voyez,
vous ne pouvez pas parler.
C'est assez sympa. Pour
la communication, c'est chouette.
(Rires)
Quitte à parler, je vais parler
d'un sujet que je maîtrise.
Je vais essayer de vous transmettre
tout ce qui peut m'animer.
J'ai plusieurs vies,
j'ai plusieurs visages.
Vous qui avez lu le programme,
vous avez un peu pris de l'avance.
Vous savez que je suis kinésithérapeute,
que j'aspire à devenir journaliste
et que je suis cavalier
de saut d'obstacles en compétition.
Alors, toutes ces choses-là,
évidemment, je vais vous en parler,
je vais vous parler du cavalier, mais
d'abord, comment est né ce cavalier ?
Dans les deux sens du terme, bien sûr,
sens littéral et métaphorique.
Moi, je suis né à Bordeaux,
de parents marocains.
Autant vous dire que la différence,
j'en connais un rayon.
J'étais déjà pas mal fourni.
Et je suis aussi né
avec une particularité,
j'ai été livré avec un défaut.
C'est-à-dire que génétiquement parlant,
j'ai été mal programmé.
J'ai eu un défaut génétique,
une petite anomalie qui s'est traduite
par un cancer, cancer de la rétine.
Alors ce mot-là il fait peur, flippant.
Cancer, maladie qui fait mourir les gens.
J'ai eu de la chance.
Au bout d'à peu près
un an et demi de soins,
j'en suis sorti avec
un peu de vision en moins.
A force de beaucoup d'amour,
beaucoup de chimio, beaucoup de chirurgie.
J'étais un gamin de 2 ans
qui avait un restant visuel.
Ça, c'est le mot préféré des médecins
à l'époque : le restant visuel.
Aux yeux de la loi
et de la médecine, j'étais aveugle.
Mais j'y voyais.
Vous voyez, c'est déjà la différence,
un truc assez sympa.
J'y voyais et pour eux,
j'étais aveugle. J'y voyais quoi ?
Finalement, je ne pouvais pas
conduire, je ne pouvais pas lire.
Donc, il a fallu trouver
un autre moyen de m'enseigner :
le braille.
Par contre, j'ai toujours pu avoir
les mêmes repères que vous, visuellement.
Donc, j'ai pu repérer des visages,
des formes, des couleurs.
Je sais à quoi ressemble le ciel,
à quoi ressemblent pas mal de choses.
Je sais à quoi ressemble
le monde, finalement.
J'ai eu cette chance-là.
Et j'ai eu une autre chance, c'est celle
d'évoluer dans le même monde que vous.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai intégré
une école tout à fait classique,
dans laquelle la seule chose différente,
c'était l'institutrice
qui connaissait le braille.
Et qui nous faisait cours,
à d'autres élèves et moi,
fallait bien apprendre à lire.
Et on n'avait pas les moyens
technologiques qu'on a aujourd'hui.
Donc, j'ai dû apprendre
sur des grosses feuilles cartonnées,
avec des machines à écrire qui sont
assez costaudes et font beaucoup de bruit.
Donc, on ne passait pas inaperçus.
Mais une fois finis les cours,
dans la cour de récréation,
on était comme tout le monde.
On était ces gamins qui jouent aux billes,
qui font de la corde à sauter,
qui jouent à chat.
Les platanes étaient pour nous.
Mais peu importe,
il y avait l’infirmerie pour ça.
Comme pour tous les autres.
Voilà, il suffisait de pas trop
se faire mal et de repartir.
Et je vous parle pas de ça par hasard.
Je crois que le fait d'avoir été mis
avec tout le monde,
personne ne s'est posé la question,
et moi non plus à l'époque.
Ça allait de soi.
Et ça m'a permis de me mesurer
aux autres, selon les mêmes critères.
Alors, certes, mes parents
m'ont toujours appris
qu'il me faudrait beaucoup plus de temps
pour faire les mêmes choses.
Et beaucoup plus d'efforts.
Faudrait que je travaille
10 fois, 15 fois, 100 fois plus
pour arriver aux mêmes résultats.
C'est ce que j'ai fait.
C'est ce que j'ai tenu à faire.
C'est ce qu'on m'a transmis,
c'est mon bagage.
Et le jour où j'ai tenu
à faire de l'équitation,
où j'osais à peine rêver
de compétition et de tout ça,
le travail a finalement été le même.
Et on a réussi à obtenir
ce que vous avez devant vous.
On a réussi à travailler,
dans le même sens que les autres.
Quand j'ai commencé l'équitation,
j'étais un cavalier comme les autres.
Il m'a fallu un peu de temps
pour trouver un club.
Mais finalement, je n'avais
pas grand chose de différent.
J'étais un débutant tout aussi
peu doué que les autres.
Et on a dû m'apprendre de la même manière
qu'on a appris aux autres.
Avec quelques indications en plus, certes,
mais on m'a appris de la même façon.
Là, je joue avec ma montre
car je ne vois pas le timer.
Du coup, j'ai une petite montre
assez sympa, qui vibre.
Et comme ça, l'air de rien,
je peux vous dire qu'il reste
à peu près 6 min à m'écouter.
Petite parenthèse.
(Rires)
Et cet apprentissage que j'ai fait...
J'étais juste un gamin
qui voulait occuper ses samedis,
qui osait à peine dire aux gens
qu'il voulait faire du cheval.
Et, souvenez-vous, j'y voyais encore.
Et à un moment donné, j'ai dû
déménager, chercher un autre club.
Et je suis tombé sur quelqu'un...
On me dit que je suis
malade de faire du cheval.
Un aveugle qui se met sur une bébête
pour sauter des barres
sans regarder où il va. Bon voilà...
Je suis tombé sur plus fou
que moi. Elle s'appelle Tiffany.
C'est ma coach depuis 10 ans.
Dès mon arrivée, elle m'a dit :
« Toi, je ne vais pas te lâcher.
Et je vais te faire faire de la compét.
C'est ton rêve, tu vas le faire. »
On a travaillé, pendant longtemps.
Elle était juste élève
monitrice à l'époque.
Et je crois qu'on avait le même rêve.
On avait cette volonté
de nous mettre, tous les deux,
sur les mêmes mesures que tout le monde.
Sur la même échelle que n'importe qui.
Et ce travail, finalement, ça a donné ça :
ça a donné quelque chose qui ressemble
à ce que fait n'importe qui,
n'importe quel cavalier
de saut d'obstacles.
J'ai enchaîné un parcours
il n'y a pas longtemps
sur le Longines Masters de Paris.
Un gros événement équestre.
Et je l'ai fait sous le parrainage
de Guillaume Canet.
La 1e fois que je l'ai rencontré...
Voilà, je n'ai que 25 ans,
moi j'étais encore... j'étais tout gêné.
Je me dis : « Il s’intéresse
à ce que je fais ! »
Et j'ai eu la chance d'être soutenu
par des cavaliers olympiques.
Tout juste médaillés de Rio l'été dernier.
J'y croyais à peine.
Ce que ça m'a montré, finalement,
ce que les gens ont vu
ce jour-là, c'est un cavalier.
Un cavalier qui, certes, n'y voit pas.
Qui a besoin de personnes
pour le guider sur le terrain.
Mais finalement :
les fautes sont les mêmes.
Le contrat technique, le même.
Et le cheval n'est pas dressé pour.
J'ai eu quelques difficultés
en début de tour,
ça s'est réglé. Tout le monde
a bien vu ce qui s'était passé.
Finalement, j'ai été jugé
de la même façon que tous.
Et c'est ça qui m'a énormément plu.
Finalement, qu'est-ce que je tire
comme leçon de tout cela ?
L'important, ce n'est pas
la différence qui saute aux yeux.
Là, à première vue, vous voyez
un aveugle devant vous.
N’ayons pas peur des mots,
vous voyez un aveugle.
Je crois que c’est une erreur
de dire que je suis un aveugle.
Je suis un aveugle,
mais je ne suis pas que ça.
Je n'y pense pas tous les matins.
Failli dire : « en me regardant
dans la glace », mais ça marche pas...
J'ai perdu ce restant visuel
la 1e année où j'ai fait de la compét
et j'ai continué.
Je me suis même senti libéré.
J'ai pu me fier à d'autres petites choses.
Faites l'expérience, fermez les yeux
et vous verrez que votre visage
se tourne, malgré tout,
vers là d'où vient le son.
C'est pareil pour moi dans la vie.
C'est une partie
de colin-maillard finalement.
Se repérer dans la ville...
Imaginez-vous : à Paris,
en pleins Champs-Élysées,
quelqu'un qui vous bande les yeux
et vous dit : « Hé, vas-y,
trouve ton chemin, on va rigoler. »
Donc c'est exactement ça.
Finalement, il n'y a pas
de difficulté insurmontable.
Et il n'y a pas besoin
de s'enfermer dans des cases.
C'est peut-être ça aussi
qui ne m'a jamais arrêté,
dans mes diverses vies,
dans mes diverses passions.
Les jeux paralympiques
n'ont été inventés qu'en 1960.
Et bien avant cela,
il y a une personne
qui n'a pas attendu qu'on lui explique
qu'il y aurait un jour des compétitions
pour les personnes handicapées.
George Eyser, un Américain, en 1904,
qui a décroché six médailles
en une journée.
Trois médailles d'or,
deux d'argent, une de bronze.
En une journée, pour les États-Unis.
C'est un gymnaste avec une jambe de bois.
Quelque chose d'assez sympa.
J'aurais pu m'en servir d'exemple.
Mais comme tous les gamins,
j'avais d'autres exemples.
En plus, je pouvais regarder
la télé, j'avais du bol.
Donc, j'ai eu, comme tous
les gosses, d'autres modèles.
Et un modèle notamment, qui est
un héros. Qui est un super-héros.
Qu'on surnomme l'homme sans peur.
Qui est avocat le jour, justicier la nuit.
Qui est Daredevil,
que vous connaissez évidemment.
Ce que m'a appris Daredevil,
c'est que, finalement,
nos barrières n’en sont que
parce qu’on leur permet d’en être.
On peut tout à fait être à la fois
notre plus grand adversaire
et notre plus grand allié.
L’important étant
de ne pas être son pire ennemi,
de ne pas faire malgré soi
mais de faire avec soi.
Et partant de là, on peut rêver de tout.
On n'est pas sûr d'y arriver.
Pour rester sur les jeux de mots,
j'aime bien les jeux de mots.
Je ne vois pas où je vais,
mais ça m'empêche pas d'y aller.
Et j'ai envie de vous demander
maintenant : que voyez-vous ?
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)
On ne m'a pas fouillé,
en entrant, je vous rassure.
C'est ma canne, tout va bien.
Mais il n'y a pas de hasard non plus.
Ça ne vient pas
d'une boutique spécialisée.
Pour le clin d’œil, j'ai acheté ça
dans une armurerie.
Voilà, un aveugle dans une armurerie.
Ça l'a beaucoup fait rire.
Parce que je voulais
un truc sympa pour ma canne.
Et puis bon, est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un petit clin d’œil à Daredevil ?
Je vous laisse libres d'imagination.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)